the origin of bitterness
is going to be anger and hurt
it starts with anger but then it
progresses to
pain it's when you kind of mill into
that pain area for far too long that you
end up with problems
and it basically matures anger into
bitterness
now you let this thing fester
it can be a catalyst into vengeful acts
it'll certainly prevent you from being
present um
what's this guy what's the guy's name
eckertoli power of now
good book it's not like
a lot of guys will read my book the
unplugged alpha and they'll be like
yeah it kind of leans in a certain
direction but i understand it
right my book would not exist had i not
gone through the
i'm going to say 20 or 30 top books on
my list and power of now is probably in
that
you know it's a little bit a little bit
woosa but it's certainly worth the read
i
i'm pretty sure i put it in my amazon
bookstore if you check that link pinned
in my top comments
now the problem with the whole
bitterness is it also facilitates a
victim mindset
so if you think about somebody you know
right now
maybe it's even you and
you're thinking about the bitterness
you can't have that level of bitterness
without some
some level of a victim mindset
which is really a loser's mindset you
know oh they crossed me
i had a couple of thoughts here to
consider i jotted down let me just
scroll down a little bit here
so here's something that you should
consider
did this person who hurt you
consciously intend to treat you in a
malicious way
did they like did they go out of your
way do they go out of their way
to wreck your life you know so that it
would cause the bitterness
because i bet you on a balance of
probability chances are they didn't
right there there may be cases from the
time
time you know time to time where it was
a personal vendetta against you maybe
something retaliatory
did you deserve it i don't know maybe
maybe not
but i think more often not they don't
intend to do it it's just that they're
putting their own agenda ahead of yours
and hurting you happens to be the
byproduct of that
the the way that i put it here in my
talking points is that your offender is
most likely solipsistic and more
concerned with their own agenda than
hurting you you guys can scroll down in
the description or just expand there i
got some of the talking points
apparently they help with keyword
searches as well
anyway so a lot of guys come to the
mano swamp looking for answers
and one of the reasons why they do is
because they get hurt
they sometimes have one itis for a girl
which is just an unhealthy attachment to
one check they think that
you know she's the only one she can only
ever be the only one rich
i have to get her back how do i get her
back
no most likely it comes from a place of
solipsism and we know women are
solipsistic they have a hard time seeing
pastoral knows that's fine
it's not a it's not a bug it's a feature
it's part of their firmware just accept
it
the whole point about this bitterness
and getting past
it is the solution becomes
it's kind of a version of forgiveness if
i'm being honest but more specifically
looking at the events in a new light so
let me give you an example
girlfriend cheats on you whatever you
get angry
then you get bitter maybe you get angry
and better
maybe you get it because maybe you read
some books somewhere maybe you watch
some youtube videos somewhere and then
and then it dawned and you
well you know women are hypergamous
which means they just want the best they
can possibly get
and kevin in sales was better than me
because
i'm taught in caretaking or whatever and
then you go get angry and you get angry
and you let it fester you watch a few
more videos and you join a reddit and
you subreddit and you start to
go back and forth with some guys
yeah that guy kevin in sales
why him why not me
i'm i feel helpless now this is [ __ ]
maybe you get some resentment built into
that with some retaliatory
thoughts right but the bottom line is
the solution to all of this
is seeing the events in a new light you
just look at it for what it is
kevin works in sales we'll call it becky
becky the girlfriend starts smashing
kevin you're no longer the best option
that's female nature does she care that
you're hurt no why
women are solid cystic they have a hard
time seeing pastoral nose it's important
for them to make sure that they're taken
care of
right they put themselves ahead of
everything else okay now we start to
understand that we see the events
in a new light then we look at him and
go oh i'm no longer bitter
i think i'm going to go do something
bigger and better than kevin from sales
you don't become bitter you become
better i could pretty much wrap up this
entire show on that note just uh
put that into a uh a clip all right
that's it we're done show's over i'm
kidding um let me get to some of these
super chats here
i gotta switch these screens over get my
notes this way there we go
chris baker what about resentment
towards people in general and the world
especially when people have been acting
so stupid in 2020 and 2021
yeah resentment so there was this audio
program
my dad gave me when i was like 19 or 20.
i can't remember who it was it might
have been
i think it was brian tracy if i'm being
honest and he was and he was talking in
one of the segments about the mind's eye
and how we perceive [ __ ]
um another good book that ties into
how the mind's eye operates is
psycho-cybernetics by maxwell maltz
very very good book but um
he was talking about how resentment and
guilt are the two most negative emotions
you can feel one's towards somebody else
and once towards yourself
and the funny thing about all these like
bitterness the resentment the anger the
guilt when it starts to fester and pile
up it's like it's like taking
poison hoping that the other guy is
going to die but you're really killing
yourself
you know it doesn't do you any good so
you know what chris's point he's talking
about especially when people have been
acting so stupid in 2020 and 20
they've been acting stupid in 2018 and
2019.
in 1999 and 2000. go back to 1999
2000 everybody thought the world was
going to end because
and you know for you younger guys out
there that are 20 years old you're not
going to remember this but
we we actually thought there was a point
in time that everything was going to
stop working planes were going to fall
out of the sky
cars were going to stop driving because
they're all you know computer controlled
every every bit of our device and and
data information was just going to
implode on itself because he said when
they created computing they didn't
engineer
into the idea that the year 2000 comes
after 1999 so they just ran up the dates
to 1999.
2000 comes around nothing happened
people were acting stupid over that for
a good six to twelve months
what else you know throughout history
humans act stupid
i've said this on twitter a few times in
the last couple of months go watch the
movie
idiocracy that movie is going to prove
to be a documentary
i'm not going to live long enough to see
it probably but i'm telling you it's
going to prove to be a documentary
mike judge that guy put some
masterpieces together not even knowing
it
anyway uh so what about resentment to
people in general and the world
especially when people have been acting
so stupid but who cares
chris it's it's you have to get to the
point of forgiveness like this
like this whole anger and bitterness
it's like you can take it as forgiveness
you can take it as
i don't care you can take it as a zfg
attitude
but really the point being is you don't
have there's only
one part of the universe that you can
control and that's yourself
you're not going to control anybody else
you're not going to control a chick
you're dating you're not going to
control your boss your business partner
you can't even control your employees to
a certain degree
control yourself control your emotions
you know it's about to cut
you know it's about coming to to peace
with that that's all it is
think like the one percent says how do
you cope with not wanting to chase hoes
and legitimately get more fulfillment
out of a traditional family
and doing this while you're a red pill
air okay so you're basically asking
about the difference between chasing
tail
and you're saying more fulfillment out
of a traditional family but i think if
you ask
a lot of men and i'm sure women too but
i mean most you guys listening are men
they're going to probably tell you after
10 or 20 years of marriage
the whole fulfillment out of traditional
family no longer
exists the social contract that you
think exists
existed in your grand dad's day maybe
your great-granddad's day depending on
how old you are when you're
watching this that social contract did
exist then
but that's changed you know you have
all the responsibility you've always had
as a man
you know as a husband as a father that
you've always had for hundreds of years
but you no longer have the authority
anymore
you no longer have the ability to you
know
a man's house is his castle and all that
stuff nope
you don't have that anymore that's been
changed
look if you want to chase tail chase
tail if you want to build a family build
a family
and do it while you're red pill aware if
you're going to do it at all in fact
i would discourage anybody from getting
married until they understand
exactly what they're walking into until
i have a chapter in my book
okay boom shameless self-promotion i
have a chapter in my book
the title of the chapter is called why
smart men don't get married
and i don't tell you don't get married i
don't tell you get married
all i tell you is all the reasons why
from a red pill lens
so if you want to march into the
slaughterhouse and go get married and
have a
traditional family and think it's going
to give you the underlying fulfillment
that you're looking for
okay do it but march into the
slaughterhouse with your eyes wide open
is all i'm saying
the biggest roi over your chasing tail
comment here
is not chasing tail is not building
fulfillment in traditional family
it's not consuming every piece of red
pill content that's out there
is chasing excellence
you don't want kevin from sales stealing
your girl be better than kevin from
sales
oh but rich there's always somebody
better than kevin you can never out
alpha the state blah blah blah blah blah
blah these are the better guys crying
they're the bitter and angry guys crying
about stuff and that's fine
people people get angry like i said
anger is a legitimate
response in the face of injustice it is
what it is
um kevin delt says unplugged alpha was
killer and extremely concise
appreciate that thank you and by the way
if you guys enjoyed the book do me a
solid go to amazon and leave a nice
written
review just let guys know what value
you've gotten out of consuming that
content
it's um it's really important to uh to
share that part
i mean give it five stars all day long
please i you know encourage you but at
least
you know like tell people what you got
out of it you know give them a give on
it
devin says uh hey rich started following
you after the tommy lahren video oh yeah
that was that was a while ago
i'm sure guys i'm sure we're gonna see
another episode from
some other trad con blondie
bombshell or thinking she's a bombshell
about how awesome she is and how dumb
men are
at some point this year it's feels like
every you know eight to ten months
something something
needs to come out so you let me know
when you see it i want to thank you got
me back my purpose since watching the
videos and have my best fourth quarter
last year and already met my goals this
year
[ __ ] a brother right on man that's
what i like to hear
don't blame snakes for doing what's in
their nature exactly
i'm sure you guys heard the story about
the scorpion and the frog crossing the
river
you know the uh too long didn't read
version of that story as the uh
the scorpion stings the frog and they
both die they both drown
so uh you know don't get mad at
you know humans for following their
nature
uh it's one of the reasons why i love
evolutionary
psychology so much i think one of my
favorite books i should probably go back
and revisit it
um what is it called the evolution of
desire david buss
such a good book evo psych is where it's
at guys
you wanna you wanna unplug from um
cognitive biases and stop listening to
dumb [ __ ]
from dumb people on dumb youtube
channels
start plugging into some evo psych
let me find the book titles that i like
here oh fingerprints of the gods was
another good one
graham hancock guys [ __ ] brilliant
that's not evo psych per se
yeah evolution of desire david buss
check it out
it's a good book don't blame snakes for
doing what's in their nature 100 percent
uh what else we got here kp says great
stuff rich keep killing that anger
not used as a conscious tool to an
immediate end becomes a choice that
pollutes your mind
and pulls you off purpose um dudes you
cannot accomplish anything great
there's absolutely no way in hell
you can put a dent in the universe no
matter how big or how small you're
aiming to do so
if you're carrying around bitterness
ain't happening
[ __ ] promise you here i'm going to
grab the
join link drop this in the chat
join and ask a question
start moving towards taking questions i
got a couple of summarized points here
i'm just going to uh i'll drop down the
chat you guys can pile in make sure you
have a good audio connection
and uh go back to my notes over here so
here's some quotes to consider from some
smart people
it is hardly possible to build anything
if frustration
bitterness and a mood of helplessness
prevail
to my point you cannot put a dent in the
universe
if you're bitter it has an underlying
notion of victimhood it has an
underlying notion of helplessness
it has an underlying notion of anger and
frustration it's
it's just a wasted mood you know
i talk about managing your f's like
they're a resource
and not giving them away for free
unnecessarily on dumb stuff that's not
deserved of it
that's kind of like if you manage your
energy correctly
you won't get bitter because you're just
going to be like all right bad [ __ ]
happened
i was angry for a second i understand
why i see it in a new light now
i'm cool with it see you later and then
you reserve your f's for something
that's more
f worthy oh rich this guy did a hit
video on you you got to go watch it
right now didn't you i know because i
don't give a [ __ ]
that's zfg man i know from personal
experience how damaging it can be
to live with bitterness and
unforgiveness i like to say it's like
taking poison and hoping your enemy will
die
and it really is that harmful to us to
live that way
here's another quote something my mom
taught me
years and years ago his life's too short
to carry around a great bucket load of
anger and resentment and bitterness and
hatred
resentment and guilt guys it's like
filling up a big burlap bag
full of bricks and throwing it over your
shoulder
all right let's carry this [ __ ]
around because everybody's going to see
me carry it and think that i'm a
big strong awesome dude and i'm
deserving of
all of their praise and blah blah
[ __ ] blah
this is essentially the narrative the
lie that we tell ourselves
men love to complicate their lives and
justify why all you got to do is take
that
bag of bricks [ __ ] throw it down and
just walk away from it
i know i make it sound simple but can
you do it
can you put that [ __ ] down and walk away
from it all right
i think i got everything here
yeah again guys the remedy to all this
[ __ ] is forgiveness
and viewing the events in a clearer
light
most of the time when you get bitter
it's because your
your belief system your um
you know your safe world theory that you
hold true to yourself
is violated and it collapses like a
house of cards you build up this big
[ __ ] story this narrative
of the deck of cards and the whole thing
just comes crashing down
oh i'm bad now i'm gonna get bitter and
hate everybody
okay that's one option you can do that
where you can see that you built your
entire [ __ ] belief system on a house
of cards and it's not stable
see you in a new light see we'll see the
world for what it is
and understand and then adapt
it's incumbent upon you as a dude to
[ __ ] grow man
ain't nobody holding your hand in the
real world they might do it in school
your mommy might do it your single mom
you might do it while you're growing up
call it your ass [ __ ] real world does
it cut off your ass
real world's got no time for that
you